what do you make
of elon musk investing with tesla
investing in bitcoin
and maybe broad broaden it out in some
of these other
you know big billionaires but also
people tied to major companies
investing in bitcoin yeah i think
michael saylor really led the charge on
that uh
he's the ceo of microstrategy that i
think they've acquired
upwards of two billion dollars in
bitcoin now started acquiring
august maybe of 2020 and he's
you know personally bought a lot of it
he bought a lot
as a treasury reserve asset for his
company microstrategy then they
leveraged up
uh on a convertible note and bought more
so he's really gone
really leading the charge in this
bitcoin
institutional adoption your conversation
with him is a really interesting one
your series of i mean series of episodes
i suppose but it's only a couple of
conversations
i guess yeah we we recorded twice five
and a half hours each
so it's about 11 hours of content and
yeah thank you it's
a lot of people have said that uh it's
the best
first principle thing they've ever seen
on bitcoin which i take no credit for
that at all
i mean i just sat down with a guy and
unleashed him he's
he's just a beast yeah but it's
fascinating
that uh his long-term vision with it
i mean i'm not sure i'm all
philosophically bought in
but if he's right if this
set of ideas are as powerful as um
he describes as you described that this
this would change the world
which as you say it's funny that a
company like microstrategy
uh might be the the the company that has
the the biggest macro effect uh on our
economy in our world
yeah the conversation reshaped my
worldview a lot too
because he framed money as energy
which i had often thought of money as
time
and it explored those connections a lot
of my writing but looking at it as
energy and then his supposition that
the purpose of life is to basically
channel energy across space and time
so we're just trying to figure out how
to channel more energy across space and
time
towards the satisfaction of aims and uh
his definition his answer to that
question what is money is it
money is the highest form of energy a
human being can channel
so it's a claim to all other forms of
energy we can manifest in the world
and that just completely reshaped how i
see it
brought in this whole other side to my
my
intellectual explorations of money can
you elaborate on that a little bit so i
understand money is time which is in
itself a really powerful idea
but money is energy and channeling
energy can you break that apart yeah
so i guess
definitely have to check out the whole
series to really get his perspective but
i'll do my best to
condense it um life
itself all forms of life are you know
they're dependent on energy right energy
fuels everything
fuels life and action and motion and all
of that
and we can say that maybe like a plant
is harnessing solar energy and then
reallocating
that into growth so its aim is to grow
towards the sun
right so it's allocating energy towards
its goal of
harnessing more solar energy kind of
thing so
and humans too
have evolved to figure out how to
harness energy in different ways
to satisfy higher and more complicated
aims
so the original energy network
that he made that he referenced was fire
right we actually learned to wield
fire as a tool in and of itself so not
only are we learning to
channel energy but we actually learn how
to
isolate energy as a tool in and of
itself
so we went into that how harnessing fire
had changed human beings and actually
this is one of the earliest examples too
of a co-evolution between
tool in our biology because when we
developed fire
we developed cooking and cooking is you
can kind of think of it as pre-digestion
in a way we're liberating these
macronutrients or making things that
otherwise would not be digestible edible
and it increases the efficiency by which
we extract
nutrients from food that's what cooking
does so when
we figured out cooking we free we
liberated all these
digestive resources that were
reallocated towards higher cognitive
development so there's this uh
evolutionary path between figuring out
fire and us becoming smarter
which which was interesting um
some other early examples he gave he
went into were missiles
and hydraulics so missiles being
we learn to hunt at a distance you know
we can't
bring down a woolly mammoth maybe with
spears and
and uh up close and personal force but
we could with spears and javelins and
slings and whatnot
and then he went into uh how we've used
water
to channel hydraulic energy so we can
basically overcome gravity we can move
you know um there's theories that the
pyramids were constructed using
the blocks removed using hydraulic
energy or using water
uh clearly we use like cargo ships and
why not to move things much more
efficiently across water than we could
the land
so this his whole view is how we keep
figuring out
better ways and more efficient ways to
harness energy and channel it
and in that perspective money has always
represented a claim on all other forms
of energy
so whatever energy couldn't be channeled
towards something useful
in the economy historically would go
into gold mining so gold became this
residual this economic this token of
the excess energy created by the market
economy
and then you could take that token of
energy and use it use it to redeem
for any other form of energy or any of
the products of energy itself
so it's i guess that's my best
approximation of it and
it just really shattered my world view
again because i'd always thought about
it as time like we spend time
sacrificing
to obtain money that we then redeemed
for commencement sacrifices from other
others but i'd never considered it
purely as energy and then it also ties
back into gold
where there was an energy expenditure
necessary to obtain gold
so there's a proof of work associated
with obtaining gold
that protected its market value all
right so you had to expend
again if market if market value of
gold's 2 000 an ounce you had to expend
1900 an ounce mining
so it kept producers honest in a way
you